[Music]
your son was born on the 4th of July
yeah Independence Day Independence Day
that's fantastic you had a son to
promote the movie you were coming out
with the year later
[Applause]
yeah when we concede I thought that when
we were conceived at time the conception
exactly for the movie company I'm like
Babe Ruth I said okay this one is gonna
come out 4th of July I think maybe your
wife had a little more to listen so he's
got he's a year old now what kind of kid
is he oh the sweetest kid you've got to
meet him Charlie he's very very sweet
he's wonderful you played games with NBC
we play games we give him a bath every
night you give your kid did you give
your kids bath get in the bathtub every
night really people take care of that
for me I ever do I have a management
company that handles it no no I bet and
we play games I make him laugh they
start that early don't they they're like
people and then they have a sense of
well they are they're very similar to
Peter why you even trying to be funny
there no I'm just like other like people
so they so well they have a sense of
humor I feel like I can even make him
laugh just by you know he's of course
non nonverbal sure but he makes great
sounds yeah great I wish I had his
capacity he screams up a storm he's got
a powerful everything then he goes oh
yeah it's very scary kind of guttural
say I don't think he sounds okay I got
to be honest with you
I bet you choke they didn't go
that's him that's it that's a column
from Lord of the Ring as he talked much
about his precious and this what I'm
curious about
he's sweet I love it when you that I
know I love you know if-- is you know I
noticed your wedding ring when you came
out which is that you always everything
you do has style to it everything down
to your wedding ring which is uh I see
you play with it a lot I do have I been
already doing that I do do that
unconsciously would you like to see it
Michaels handing stuff all over it right
let me see let me see your your wedding
well then we're now we're married to
each other we so we could be which is
legal in this state
yeah let me see you are writing in here
I don't have I do can you see what that
says those glasses won't help you oh my
god you're blind this is insane this is
crazy the audience looks like a cloud of
beef bouillon right now it says peaches
plus patches yes what does that mean
well she's peaches I'm patches okay how
did I'm curious how did she get the
nickname peaches well because well the
beaches because she's sweet and like a
peach like a juicy and sweet peach okay
so how did you get the nickname packs
well patches I have a lovely
distribution of hair on my torso
yes consider that as long as you like
here here I have I have a couple of I
have a couple of other other little
adornments of a fluff what for their
input you're saying it's inconsistent no
no you misunderstand
I've got I've got something here that
occurs it's a it's a nice couple of
patches but and here's the important
part this is where whence the name comes
from one is inconsistent with the other
this is fluffier Oh Oh before I need
some it is asymmetrical it's you're
getting it that's right right on the
nose that's it asymmetrical I used to I
used to try the terrifying interview
it's the truck you do even it up but she
said no no don't I like you sweet
patches I like you patches unpatch ins
and then
and then and then I said I love that 70s
hit patches I'm dependin on you say yes
is that nice that's and I said yeah
we'll do the family through my sign it's
all been left up to you you remember
that yes we don't have to remember
anymore you just sang all of it that's
correct now yours is a beautiful band of
gold do you remember that yeah no yes
you're right read it again but there's a
band of dolls I like that song you've
been gone all that's left of gold the
dreams I hold is a band of gold and the
memory of what love could be
[Applause]
you